hablemos del origen de esta crisis
política entendiendo a dos personajes
claves cuéntenos quiénes son el clérigo
moqtada al zar y el ex primer ministro
pro iraní nouri al mickey que está
detrás del actual candidato al sudario
qué tal mucho gusto maría
bueno avanzado es un clérigo chiita como
bien mencionado pero aquí lo importante
tener en mente es que cuando decimos que
es un clérigo no quiere decir que se
dedique únicamente no existe una iglesia
como tal y que una de las vertientes
políticas más fuertes en muchos de los
países del medio oriente es lo que se
llama como islam político entonces
cuando decimos que montado saber es un
cargo decimos que es un teórico y un
político en misma medida y mientras que
no haría al malikí es el previo bueno
fue el primer ministro de irak y siempre
se ha visto a al malikí como uno una
figura política altamente
vinculada a irán
porque están tan peleados podríamos
decir es porque al malikí se ve como una
figura muy cercana a irán mientras que
la variedad de islam político y a pesar
de ser chiíta el movimiento del zar
tiene como una de sus principales
ideologías la no intervención entonces
todo lo que suene a una línea alinearse
ya sea con eeuu con con irán o con
cualquier otra potencia extranjera
al-sadr o lo más probable es que lo va a
rechazar y lo que estamos viendo es
alzado y precisamente haciendo valer su
peso político para rechazar cualquier
cosa que parezca como un primer ministro
que se alinea con cualquier potencia
extranjera y a propósito de este peso
político desde las elecciones de octubre
el parlamento no ha logrado los dos
tercios de votos que necesita para
elegir a un presidente y que es el
primer paso para nombrar a un primer
ministro profundizamos un poco más en
qué radica la diferencia política y cuál
es el papel de la corriente sadrista que
usted ya mencionaba
es una situación muy complicada porque
actualmente irak es un país
políticamente muy diverso bueno también
étnicamente y religiosamente es un país
muy diverso y es muy difícil que
cualquier partido político alcance a
lograr la mayoría absoluta que serían
por lo menos tener la mitad en este
momento la mayoría de los actores
políticos ya renunciaron a la idea de
poder tener un presidente elegir un
presidente porque para tener un
presidente necesitan dos terceras partes
de los de la cámara de representantes
sino en este momento no hay una
coalición que llegue ni siquiera a la
mitad más uno para elegir un primer
ministro mucho menos van a alcanzar a
las dos terceras partes para tener un
presidente en ese es en esos casos si no
se puede asignar un presidente
quien tiene la responsabilidad de
asignar al jefe del ejecutivo en este
caso sería la cámara de representantes y
es lo que ahorita están buscando hacer
pero con tanta diversidad y tanta
polarización se ve muy muy difícil que
haya una condición estable sí y como lo
que ocurra en la política nacional de
irak puede cambiar el ajedrez político
en medio oriente sobre todo en las
relaciones con irán y con eeuu
bueno eso siempre es es un poco más
especulativo pero ciertamente lo que
estamos viendo es una
pues que está ganando mucha fuerza los
movimientos contra nacionalistas
y eso lo que nos dice es que ciertamente
tanto irán cuánto eeuu van a tener
bastantes más dificultades en proyectar
su poder especialmente ahora que eeuu
está enfocando más sus intenciones
internacionales en la competencia de
grandes potencias con estos con rusia
con china y que medio oriente está
teniendo un papel un poquito más
secundario se vuelve más caro más
costoso poder hacer valer tú tus tus
políticas o tu agenda en irak y lo mismo
aplica para irán que ahorita está
teniendo menos ingresos petroleros
porque hay mucho más petróleo ruso con
descuentos por las sanciones que era
donde normalmente irán mete a sus de sus
barriles de petróleos en el mercado
internacional
entonces tanto irán como eeuu
les va a salir más caro sin proyectar su
agenda
al final del día no parece ser que irak
pueda tener un gobierno estable en los
próximos meses será poco probable